How does "The Batman's" explosive finale stack up
to "Batman & Robin's" pun-filled
finale? Does "Batman v. Superman:
Dawn of Justice" wear the kryptonite crown when
it comes to Bat-finales? Holy climaxes, Batman!
There aren't a whole lot of people out there
who would argue that Joel Schumacher's 1997
film "Batman & Robin" was a masterpiece. The
bloated, flashy sequel to the 1995 hit "Batman
Forever" dialed the silliness way up to an
unprecedented degree. While the television
series from 1966 starring Adam West was also
very goofy, the humor was intentional. None of
the jokes in "Batman & Robin" land and the rest
of it is basically an amusement park stunt show.
The climax of the film is no different. With
Gotham City frozen, it's up to Batman, Robin,
and Batgirl to save the day. While that
isn't a terrible premise for a fun and
campy adventure film, it's so noisy and
cluttered that you can't appreciate any
of the heroics that we're supposed to find so
exciting. On top of that, the characters are so
devoid of charisma and depth that we can't even
force ourselves to care what happens to them.
With a few changes in the dialogue, casting, and
tone, this could have been a loving big-budget
tribute to the 1966 series. Instead, it
comes across as a cynical toy commercial.
"You're about to become compost!"
After the dark and twisted "Batman Returns," the
franchise took a notably more family-friendly
approach with its next installment,
"Batman Forever." The film is big,
bold, and incredibly uneven. While it contains
some staggering imagery, kinetic cinematography,
and a fun performance from Jim Carrey as The
Riddler, there isn't much of a story happening.
The action set pieces are linked
together by scenes that hint at
interesting ideas and possibilities
that never get a chance to develop.
"Nice bike."
"Hang out at a lot of biker bars, Bruce?"
Bruce coming to terms with his own rage over
the murder of his parents in order to help the
grieving Dick Grayson cope with his own tragedy
could have led to a thrilling conclusion, where
the heroes finally suit up and work together.
Unfortunately, the conflict between them is
limited to a few arguments with no substance. So
as huge and visually riveting as Batman and Robin
facing off against The Riddler and Two-Face may be
on a purely cinematic level, the lack of any real
emotional resonance leaves this otherwise
mostly entertaining film feeling hollow.
Tim Burton's second film about the Dark Knight,
"Batman Returns," has all the ingredients of a
masterpiece. For one thing, it features an
incredible cast playing iconic characters.
Also, Burton had just come off of a major creative
victory with the stunning and sentimental modern
fairytale "Edward Scissorhands," suggesting
his next project would be his magnum opus.
There are elements of genius here, but just
like "Batman Forever," the story linking
them together is paper-thin. The tragedy of
Oswald Cobblepot seeking revenge on a city that
rejected him could have been the perfect
motivation for a truly maniacal villain.
Bruce and Selina's doomed romance could
have set up one of the all-time greatest
love stories. But none of it leads to anything.
"Hey stud. I thought we had something together."
"We do.”
Most of the character motivations are as murky
as sewer water, making it difficult to understand
why anything happening even matters. This makes it
virtually impossible to get invested in the film's
climax. All the primary players are together,
but we're not quite sure what brought them there.
Still, the Penguin's death is truly unsettling,
as is Selina's even stranger murder of Max Shreck.
If nothing else, you remember what happens,
even if you're not sure why they happen.
Some people may consider this a little high for
the original "Batman" feature film. After all,
many fans consider it a borderline parody of
the character. However, the film is closer
to the style and substance of the comics of
the time than many fans might like to admit,
and at least the tone is
consistent throughout. Also,
unlike some earlier entries on this list,
the humor is intentional and actually funny.
"Listen to these riddles. Tell me if you interpret
them as I do. 1. What has yellow skin and writes?"
"A ballpoint banana!"
"Right."
The movie is almost the greatest hits of
the television series. The Penguin, Riddler,
Joker, and Catwoman have joined forces for world
domination. Through a series of fiendish plans,
this unholy alliance gets close to
accomplishing their dastardly goals,
but Batman and Robin never give up. With
lots of comedy, exciting plot twists,
and a splash of romance, this film succeeds
in delivering a crowd-pleasing experience.
The finale even features an all-out battle
royale aboard a submarine, with Batman and
Robin clocking henchmen left and right, sending
them into the sea. At one point, Batman takes on
a series of thugs while cradling a cat in one arm,
before sending it off in a tiny, inflatable raft.
It's bright, colorful, intentionally
silly, and the ending does not disappoint.
After the brilliant heights achieved in 2008's
"The Dark Knight," there was no way Christopher
Nolan was going to top himself. That being said,
"The Dark Knight Rises" makes a valiant attempt at
doing just that. Its scale is bigger, the tone is
relentless, and Bane — though not as charismatic a
character as the Joker — is a complex adversary
capable of pushing Batman to the very brink.
The problem lies in the decision to make this
a concluding chapter of a trilogy, rather than
the Batman's next adventure. After setting
up this fascinating universe in the previous
installments, we were denied the chance to see new
interpretations of other fan-favorite characters.
This Batman story was ending just as it
began. This led to an overly complex and
confusing plot that had to both establish new
characters and tie them into Batman's origin,
instead of standing on their own.
While the film is still epic in scope and
packed with phenomenal action sequences,
story inconsistencies and sudden
revelations weigh the whole thing down.
Still, the image of Batman possibly flying
off to his death to save the city is powerful,
and the suggestion that John Blake
(aka Robin) is going to take up his
mantle allows the world to live on in
the imaginations of fans everywhere.
The first cinematic pairing of Batman and
Superman may not have been what everyone expected,
but it did result in some pretty great moments
that almost outshine the film's weaknesses.
The ending is a prime example of all the
things that do and do not work in the film.
For instance, the confusing plot
orchestrated by Lex Luthor to have
Batman and Superman fight to the death
is conveniently resolved when Superman
inadvertently informs Batman that
their mothers share the same name.
"You're letting him kill Martha."
Also, Superman's sacrifice is
both overblown and unnecessary.
We just met this Superman in the previous film,
and we're already being asked to mourn his death
when we've had very little time to get to
know him. It's treated like an enormously
tragic moment but it comes practically out of
nowhere. Conversely, the inclusion of Wonder
Woman gives us the chill-inducing moment where we
finally get to see DC's trinity stand together.
Just like the rest of the film, many of the
climax's details are muddled and strange,
but the simple excitement of having
three classic heroes joining forces
to defeat a common enemy is absolutely thrilling.
Matt Reeves' attempt to reconnect Batman to his
noir detective roots has, appropriately enough,
a dark ending that feels like something out
of Dashiell Hammett or Raymond Chandler.
Gotham has been largely destroyed, the
result of Riddler's plan to detonate
bombs near the seawalls surrounding the
city, sending rushing waters through
the streets and nearly killing hundreds
of citizens gathered at a local arena.
Thankfully, Batman and Catwoman were there
to help out, battling Riddler-wannabes
attempting to anonymously amplify the
supervillain's destructive efforts.
Although they save characters like Bella Real and
the late Mayor Mitchell's son, anybody you can
reasonably call a "good guy" in this film limps
into the shadows at the end, licking their wounds.
Catwoman, realizing Batman is forever linked
with Gotham, leaves the city. Bruce Wayne,
newly burdened by realizations about his
beloved parents that make his mission of
vengeance far more muddled, says in voiceover:
"The city is angry, scared ... like me."
With many of Gotham's most powerful men
on both sides now dead, opportunities
seem to be opening up for folks like
the Penguin. Riddler, now in prison,
has a next-door neighbor at Arkham who
speaks of clowns and a "comeback story."
If nothing else, the end of "The Batman"
seems to be setting up one heckuva sequel.
"The Dark Knight" is probably considered the
best film on this list. It picked up the reins
of "Batman Begins" and built an even bigger and
menacing world than before. Of course, Heath
Ledger's performance as the Joker was instantly
legendary and remains a major contributing factor
to the film's success, but "The Dark Knight"
is still an epic by any and every measure.
Which is why the end is such a letdown.
Not to say that it's bad by any means,
it's just that the rest of the film to this point
had been so dynamic and spectacular that the idea
of waiting to see if criminals on a boat will
choose to destroy another boat doesn't measure up.
Also, we've seen Batman and
the Joker face off on top of
a building before, and it was much
more emotionally gratifying in 1989.
Yes, Harvey Dent's turn to evil following
the murder of Rachel Dawes is tragic,
and the decision to let Batman take the rap
for his crimes perfectly demonstrates what
makes him a great hero, but his defeat
of the Joker falls a little flat. This
is an oversimplification of the ending, of course,
but one can't help and wonder what happened to the
amazing momentum built up in the first two acts.
The 1989 release of Tim Burton's "Batman" was the
introduction to the concept of a "dark" Batman
for many audiences. While comic book readers
had been well aware of the character's many
gothic exploits, your average moviegoer probably
just knew the Adam West Batman up to that point.
The film is tonally inconsistent, with
a serviceable — if underwhelming — plot.
But it's all elevated by its ending. While the
rest of the film is certainly entertaining and
still worth a re-watch today, it's the emotional
impact of the ending that allows the movie
to stand tall as still being one of the very
best cinematic outings for the caped crusader.
"You killed my parents."
"What? What are you talking about?"
"I made you, you made me first."
When it's revealed that the Joker was
the man who gunned down his parents,
Batman pursues the mad clown through
Gotham City and to the top of a church.
From here on out, Batman's mission isn't just
about protecting his city — he's out for revenge.
Against the shadowy backdrop
of the towering cathedral,
Joker tries everything to prevent Batman from
seeking justice, but it is ultimately futile.
Despite the fact that this confrontation, and the
motivations behind it, doesn't exactly honor the
comics, all is forgiven, because the final moments
are so emotionally and narratively satisfying.
"Batman Begins" is so different from
any of the films that came before that
it's hard to imagine it was released a
mere eight years after "Batman & Robin."
The next two films in this trilogy would take this
grounded reality even further, to the point that
they almost cease to be Batman movies and become
movies that happen to feature Batman. "Begins"
however, is still holding onto some of the
more outrageous elements of Batman's comic book
origins. The third act, with Scarecrow's nightmare
toxin causing horrific hallucinations and the city
of Gotham tearing itself apart, plays out like
something right out of the pages of a comic book.
There are innocent citizens losing their minds
and a horse blowing flames from its nose — it
is absolute chaos, and Batman is using
everything he has to stop it from getting
worse. The most rewarding moment, though, has
to be Batman's final showdown with Ra's al Ghul.
The entire film sees Bruce trying to prove that
murder isn't justice. So when he tells Ra's
"I won't kill you.
But I don't have to save you."
It's a brilliant moment that makes
you want to stand up and cheer.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite Batman movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.